So we want to read in more stocks
into a combined dataframe.
Start with the code we used to build
our dataframe with the SPY data.
Then define a list with
the required stock symbols.
Now we can write a for loop to read and
join each stock into
the dataframe just like SPY.
So here's the for loop which takes
each symbol in the symbols list and
joins it to our main dataframe.
Let's go ahead and print this.
Oops.
There is an error.
Reading the error message carefully,
we observe that index column
Adj Close has an overlap.
What is happening here is that,
irrespective of the stock
the column we are extracting
each time is named Adj Close.
So the join method is confused as
to what to name it in the result.
Column names must be unique.
As professor described earlier,
we would like each stock symbol as
the corresponding column name or header.
So we add these two lines.
This renames the column Adj Close
to the respective stock symbol.
Now let's see the output.
Here you go,
everything is finally in place.